REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK, THANK YOU.
AND JOINING US NOW, SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES,
ALEX AZAR.
MR. SECRETARY, AS WE SAID, AN
FDA ADVISORY PANEL IS GOING TO
BE CONSIDERING EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE PFIZER
VACCINE ON THURSDAY.
TWO QUESTIONS, FIRST OF ALL, IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THE TECHNICAL
INFORMATION THAT PFIZER HAS
PRESENTED THAT RAISES ANY RED
FLAGS, AND SECOND, ASSUMING THAT
THE PANEL APPROVES, HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE THE FDA TO GIVE THE
GREEN LIGHT AND FOR THE VACCINE
TO BE DISTRIBUTED?
>> Secretary Azar: SO, CHRIS,
I HAVE NOT HEARD OF ANY RED
FLAGS, BUT I WILL HAVE TO LEAVE
THAT TO THE CAREER SCIENTISTS AT
FDA WHO ARE DIGGING THROUGH ALL
OF THE DATA IN TERMS OF TIMING.
ASSUMING EVERYTHING IS ON TRACK
AND THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE GOES
WELL, WE COULD SEE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE PFIZER VACCINE WITHIN
DAYS AFTER THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THEN MODERNA ONE
WEEK LATER IS THERE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND SOME EARLY DAYS
AFTER THAT, BUT I’M GOING TO
LEAVE MIGHT LEAVE THAT TO THE
FDA CAREER SCIENTISTS TO
DETERMINE IF EVERYTHING IS ON
TRACK.
>> Chris: BUT IF THE PANEL
APPROVES ON DECEMBER 10TH, HOW
SOON WITH THE VACCINE, THE
PFIZER VACCINE, BE OUT FOR
PEOPLE?
AND >> Secretary Azar: REALLY
WITHIN DAYS.
WE’VE SAID 24 HOURS WITHIN GREEN
LIGHTING WE WILL SHIFT TO ALL OF
THE STATES AND TERRITORIES THAT
WE WORK WITH AND WITHIN HOURS
THEY CAN BE VACCINATED.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT-ELECT
BIDEN SAYS THAT HIS TRANSITION
TEAM HAS LOOKED AT THE
ADMINISTRATION’S DISTRIBUTION
PLAN AND THAT THEY HAVE FOUND
SOME PROBLEMS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS NO DETAILED PLAN.
THAT WE’VE SEEN ANYWAY AS TO HOW
YOU GET THE VACCINE OUT OF A
CONTAINER INTO AN INJUNCTION
SYRINGE INTO SOMEBODY’S ARM.
>> Chris: IS THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT WRONG TO
>> Secretary Azar: WITH ALL
RESPECT, THAT’S JUST NONSENSE.
WE HAVE COMPREHENSIVE PLANS FROM
THE CDC WORKING WITH 64 PUBLIC
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS OUR GOVERNORS HAVE
LAID OUT VERY DETAILED PLANS
THAT WE’VE WORKED WITH THEM ON.
WE ARE LEVERAGING OUR RETAIL
PHARMACIES, HOSPITALS, OR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS, OR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS.
WE HAVE THE KITS THAT HAVE THE
SYRINGES, THE NEEDLES, THE PPE
TO ADMINISTER.
THIS IS BEING MICROMANAGED AND
CONTROLLED BY THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY AS WELL AS OUR
INCREDIBLE PRIVATE SECTOR.
WE DO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
VACCINATIONS A YEAR, WE ARE
LEVERAGING THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
KNOWN AND THAT WORK HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Chris: THOUGHT THAT THIS IS
THE ADMINISTRATION’S PROBLEM,
BUT YOU ORIGINALLY PROMISED THAT
THERE WOULD BE 300 MILLION DOSES
OF THE VACCINE BY THE END OF THE
YEAR END IT NOW LOOKS LIKE IT’S
GOING TO BE ROUGHLY ABOUT 10% OF
THAT, 35-40 MILLION DOSES
BECAUSE OF VARIOUS SUPPLY
PROBLEMS ON THE PART OF THE
VACCINE MAKERS.
SO THIS ISN’T GOING TO GO JUST
ACCORDING TO THE BOOK, THERE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME OBSTACLES.
>> Secretary Azar: WELL,
CHRIS, WE ARE LOOKING AT REALLY
HISTORIC A COMPLIMENT.
SIX MONTHS FROM WHEN THE
PRESIDENT’S DIRECTION, I CREATED
OPERATION WARP SPEED, WE’RE
LOOKING AT HAVING MULTIPLE
VACCINES FDA APPROVED IN CLOSE
TO 40 MILLION DOSES OF
FDA-APPROVED VACCINE RELEASABLE
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
WHAT I’VE ALWAYS SAID IS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOSES OF DOSES BY
THE END OF THE YEAR, 40 MILLION
RELEASABLE AS WELL AS A
COMPARABLE AMOUNT THAT WILL BE
GOING THROUGH FINAL QUALITY
CONTROL FOR RELEASE IN JANUARY
AND IN HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOSES FROM MULTIPLE
MANUFACTURERS AS WE GO INTO NEXT
YEAR, REALLY IT’S A HISTORIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND IS THE LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
IT’S WHY WE NEED PEOPLE TO HANG
IN THERE WITH WASHING HER HANDS,
WATCHING THE DISTANCE, WEARING
THEIR FACE COVERINGS.
WHEN THEY CAN WATCH THEIR
DISTANCE BECAUSE THOSE BRIGHT
DAYS ARE AHEAD AND WE WANT
EVERYBODY TO BE THERE TO GET
THERE VACCINATION.
>> Chris: BUT THERE IS A HITCH
IN THIS AND THAT IS AS MANY AS
40% OF AMERICANS ACCORDING TO
POLLS SAY THEY MAY NOT GET THE
VACCINE AND ONE OF THE REASONS
IS BECAUSE CONCERN ABOUT
POLITICS.
I WANT TO PUT UP A TWEET.
ON NOVEMBER 9TH THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED "THE U.S. FDA AND THE
DEMOCRATS DIDN’T WANT TO HAVE ME
GET A VACCINE WIN PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION, SO INSTEAD, IT CAME
OUT FIVE DAYS LATER AND WHEN THE
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
CALLED IN THE FDA COMMISSIONER
TWICE THIS WEEK TO ASK WHY IT’S
TAKING THE AGENCY SO LONG TO
APPROVE THE VACCINE, THE FDA
COMMISSIONER, STEPHEN HAHN, FELT
THE NEED TO WRITE THIS.
"WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SCIENTISTS TAKE THE TIME THEY
NEED TO MAKE AN APPROPRIATE
DECISION.
IF MR. SECRETARY, WHY NOT STOP
THE POLITICS AND LET THE
SCIENTISTS DO THEIR JOB?
>> Secretary Azar: THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT I’VE DONE AND I
REASSURED YOU AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENED.
FIVE INDEPENDENT CHECKS,
INDEPENDENT DATA SAFETY
MONITORING BOARD, INDEPENDENT
DRUG COMPANY REVIEWING THE
DATA --
>> Chris: SIR -- I UNDERSTAND
THAT, BUT YOU’VE GOT THE
PRESIDENT TWEETING THAT SOMEHOW
THE DECISION ON ONE TO RELEASE
THE VACCINE WAS AN EFFORT TO
DEFEAT HIM IN THE ELECTION.
YOU’VE GOT THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
OF STAFF CALLING THE FDA
COMMISSIONER AND SAYING LET’S
GET GOING FASTER.
YOU MAY BE LETTING THE
SCIENTISTS DO THE JOB, BUT
PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE DON’T
APPEAR TO BE.
>> Secretary Azar: THE FACTS
JUST SO THAT THE FIVE
INDEPENDENT CHECKS WE PUT IN THE
SYSTEM ARE WHAT ARE DRIVING THIS
TRAIN HERE AND WE’RE ALSO GOING
TO WORK TO HELP IMPROVE VACCINE
CONFIDENCE, WORKING SPECIALLY
WITH TRUSTED TRUSTED VOICES AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BUT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS GOING TO
BE AS WE PROGRESSIVELY ROLL OUT
VACCINES TO PEOPLE, THE POSITIVE
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY HAVE BY
WORD-OF-MOUTH AND REFERENCE ARE
GOING TO BE WHAT REALLY DRIVE I
THINK INCREASING VACCINE
CONFIDENCE AS WE SEE THE END OF
THE DAY OF THIS PANDEMIC
EVENTUALLY.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, LET’S
TURN FROM THE VACCINE TO THE
TERRIBLE SITUATION THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN RIGHT NOW.
AS I SAID, WE ARE SEEING A
RECORD NUMBER OF COVID CASES,
HOSPITALIZATIONS, AND DEATHS,
AND HERE’S WHAT WE HEARD THIS
WEEK FROM THE HEAD OF THE CDC,
DR. ROBERT REDFIELD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REALITY IS DECEMBER AND
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY ARE GOING
TO BE ROUGH TIMES.
I ACTUALLY BELIEVE THEY’RE GOING
TO BE THE MOST DIFFICULT TIME IN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH HISTORY OF
THIS NATION.
>> Chris: SECRETARY AZAR,
ISN’T THIS THE RESULT OF A
MASSIVE FAILURE BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION?
>> Secretary Azar: CHRIS, WE
ARE SEEING THE SURGEON CASES AND
ENTERED STATES BUT ALSO IN
GERMANY, FRANCE, THE U.K.,
SPAIN.
IT’S ABOUT BEHAVIOR AND
COLD-WEATHER.
PEOPLE ARE GOING INDOORS, THEY
ARE NOT MINDING THE THREE Ws.
THEY ARE NOT WEARING THEIR FACE
COVERINGS.
WE ARE ENGAGED IN INDOOR
BEHAVIORS WHERE WE LET OUR GUARD
DOWN.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO RENEW THEIR
COMMITMENT, BUT WE ARE ALSO NOT
WITHOUT TOOLS.
WE HAVE COMPLETE VISIBILITY,
THANKS TO TOOLS THAT I BUILT
HERE EARLIER THIS YEAR SO THAT
WE KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON IN THE
NATION’S HOSPITALS.
WE ARE BEING PROACTIVE IN
REACHING OUT TO THEM.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT PEOPLE
KNOW THAT WE ARE WORKING TO
PROTECT THEM.
THEY ARE GETTING SUPPLIES.
>> Chris: I UNDERSTAND -- LET
ME ASK YOU -- SECRETARY AZAR,
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE TOOLS.
LET’S JUST TAKE THE ISSUE OF
MASKS.
HERE IS WHAT PRESIDENT-ELECT
BIDEN SAID THIS WEEK.
>> I’M GOING TO ASK THE PUBLIC
FOR 100 DAYS TO MASK, JUST 100
DAYS TO MASK.
IT NOT FOREVER, 100 DAYS.
>> Chris: BUT BACK ON
APRIL 3RD, WHEN THE CDC
DIRECTOR, DR. ROBERT REDFIELD
FIRST RECOMMENDED THAT ALL
AMERICANS WEAR MASKS, HERE’S
WHAT HAPPENED, SIR.
>> WE KNOW THAT A FACE BARRIER
CAN ACTUALLY INTERRUPT THE
NUMBER OF VIRUS PARTICLES THAT
CAN GO FROM ONE PERSON TO THE
OTHER.
>> SO IT’S VOLUNTARY, YOU DON’T
HAVE TO DO IT.
THEY SUGGESTED IT FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME.
BUT THIS IS VOLUNTARY.
I DON’T THINK I’M GOING TO BE
DOING IT.
>> Chris: IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAD WORN A MASK THEN AND URGED
EVERYONE TO WEAR A MASK THEN,
BACK IN APRIL, THE WAY JOE BIDEN
IS RIGHT NOW, WOULDN’T WE BE IN
MUCH BETTER SHAPE?
>> Secretary Azar: CHRIS, I
WELCOME VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
THE CLUB SINCE THE MIDDLE OF
APRIL, THE PRESIDENT’S
GUIDELINES FOR REOPENING --
>> Chris: THE PRESIDENT-ELECT,
SIR.
HE’S THE PRESIDENT-ELECT.
>> Secretary Azar: THE
PRESIDENT HAS CALLED MASKS
PATRIOTIC ACTS.
EVERYONE OF HIS TOP ADVISORS.
TOP ADVISORS SAYING WHERE YOUR
MASK.
WE TALK ABOUT THE DATA.
AT 1 METER IF TWO PEOPLE WHETHER
MASKS IT CAN REDUCE VIRAL
TRANSMISSION BY 72%.
PROTECTING BOTH THE SOURCE AND
THE RECIPIENT, WE’VE GOT THE
DATA, MASKS WORK, WE ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE, PLEASE WEAR A MASK WHEN
YOU CAN’T ENGAGE IN SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
>> Chris: FIRST OF ALL, IF THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN,
SECRETARY AZAR, AND SECONDLY,
THE FACT IS THE PRESIDENT SET ON
THE FIRST DAY, APRIL 30, THAT HE
WASN’T GOING TO WEAR A MASK.
HE DIDN’T WEAR A MASK IN PUBLIC
FOR THREE MONTHS UNTIL JULY AND
JUST LAST NIGHT AT THAT RALLY IN
GEORGIA, NOT ONLY DIDN’T HE WEAR
A MASK, BUT I WAS WATCHING THE
RALLY.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE PACKED
TOGETHER, NONE I COULD SEE
WEARING A MASK.
THAT IS A DIRECT VIOLATION OF
WHAT THE CDC AND YOU ARE
RECOMMENDING.
>> Secretary Azar: CHRIS, OUR
ADVICE IS ALWAYS THE SAME, WASH
HER HANDS, WATCH HER DISTANCE.
WHERE FACE COVERINGS WHEN YOU
CAN’T WASH HER DISTANCE AND BE
CAREFUL OF THE SETTINGS LIKE
OVERCROWDED BARS AND RESTAURANTS
ARE MULTIFAMILY HOUSEHOLD
GATHERINGS.
GOING TO LET YOUR GUARD DOWN AND
TAKE YOUR FACE COVERING OFF.
OUR ADVICE IS THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF THE SETTING.
>> Chris: AND REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT IGNORES IT
OR NOT?
>> Secretary Azar: THE
REGARDLESS OF THE SETTING, OUR
ADVICE REMAINS THE SAME AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS CALLED MASK
WEARING PATRIOTIC.
WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO WHERE
FACE COVERINGS WHEN THEY CAN’T
MAINTAIN THEIR SOCIAL DISTANCE.
>> Chris: FINALLY, YOU SAID
THIS RECENTLY ABOUT LOCKDOWNS.
YOU DON’T NEED LOCKDOWNS, THE
DATA CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE THE
INTERVENTIONS WE NEED ARE
SIMPLE.
THEY ARE DEMONSTRATED, THEY ARE
PROVEN, BUT THEY ARE NOT
FORCING -- THEY’RE NOT FORCING
PEOPLE TO STAY IN THEIR HOME,
SHUTTING DOWN OUR BUSINESSES,
SHUTTING OUR SCHOOLS.
MS. CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM
WRONG TO
SAY WHEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, MANY PLACES RUNNING
OUT OF ICU BEDS BECAUSE THERE IS
SUCH A SURGE OF HOSPITALIZATION,
IS HE WRONG TO SAY THAT HE’S
GOING TO IMPOSE SOME
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS?
>> Secretary Azar: CHRIS, OUR
COMMUNITY MITIGATION EFFORTS
HAVE TO BE BASED IN SCIENCE AND
EVIDENCE OR WE LOSE PUBLIC
SUPPORT AND COMPLIANCE FOR THEM.
WE KNOW THAT OUR WORKPLACES, OUR
UNIVERSITIES, OUR K-12 SCHOOLS,
FLYING THROUGH AIRPLANES ARE NOT
MAJOR VECTORS OF DISEASE
TRANSMISSION.
IT’S OVERCROWDED INDOOR
RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
IT IS MULTIHOUSEHOLD INDOOR
GATHERINGS WHERE WE LET OUR
GUARD DOWN.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO
PROTECT AGAINST.
IF WE GO TOO FAR -- AND WE DEFER
TO GOVERNORS ON THE STEPS THEY
NEED TO TAKE.
IT’S THEIR CALL, BUT IF WE GO
BEYOND SCIENCE AND EVIDENCE, WE
WILL UNDERMINE PUBLIC SUPPORT --
AS DR. FAUCI SAYS, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE WHY THEY SHOULD WEAR FACE
COVERINGS.
MORE THAN MANDATING IT, GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND WHY IT
MATTERS TO PROTECT THEM AND
THEIR LOVED ONES TO WHERE FACE
COVERINGS.
AND THAT’S OUR JOB, CONVINCING
PEOPLE OF SCIENCE AND
EVIDENCE-BASED INTERVENTIONS.
>> Chris: WELL, I AGREE WITH
YOU AS YOU SAY RIGHT THERE, WEAR
A MASK.
I WISH EVERYONE DID.
TUCKER TERRY, THANK YOU, THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME THIS WEEKEND, WE